[موسيقى]
حب ورغبه ونشوى وحوار اربعه نهود وامراتان
هذا ليس مشهدا من افلام البورنو التي ادمن
البعض مشاهدتها وليس مؤامره حبكت من اجل
اقصاء الرجال او القضاء على البشريه
هي حكايه حب لم تحكى فالعلاقات المثليه
بين النساء ليست مجرد قصه من قصص الف ليله
وليله بل كانت ولا تزال جزءا من الطبيعه
علاقات قمعتها المجتمعات الذكوريه وحصلتها
الاديان فبات حتى الحديث عنها تشديفا
وشذوذنا ان تكوني امراه ومثليه جنسيا في
فلك الممنوع
اجبرت على الزواج بالقوه لما كان عمري 16
سنه
من ناحيتي ما كان في اي انجذاب جنسي او
عاطفي او نهايت الزواج بالقوه بعد ثلاثه
او اربعه اشهر اكتشفت ميول الجنسيه عندما
كنت في المرحله الثانويه وقت ما كان عندي
معرفه بمفهوم المثليه الجنسيه لكن بعد
جمعيه بدات اطلاعي على انواع الجنسيه همم
عن طريق يوتيوبرز امريكيه مثليتين كانوا
بيعرضوا حياتهم الخاصه همم وافتح حسيت
يعني استحق هذه السعاده استحق انه يكون
عندي حبيبه واعيش معها حياتي في السعوديه
ما كنت اجروا نهائيا ان اتكلم عن هذا
الشيء كان فقد التكلم عن رغباتنا الجنسيه
حتى الغير مثليه كان يعتبر تابوه فما
بالكم بالمثليه
تعرفت ما ودع على ساره في مكه عام 2016
هناك بدات قصه حبهما وامام استحاله تقبل
المجتمع لعلاقتهما قرر العرب الى مكان امن
واستقر تاما عن في المانيا منذ 2019 بعد
ان حازتاه على اللجوء الانساني
في السعوديه ما وضعنا نفسنا المواجهه مع
المجتمع همم كان كل همنا فقط ان احنا نكون
في مكان امن لكن لما طلعنا بدانا نعرض عن
حياتنا نتكلم عن علاقتنا عن كيف كل ما كنا
في السعوديه وكيف الان حياته صارت
[موسيقى]
السعوديه هي الجحيم بالنسبه لي كامراه
اولا قبل كوني مثليه ومصير للاسف في
السعوديه راح يكون امه رضوخ واني اكون
تعيسه او همم الاسبوع على الزواج او السجن
المهم يا حبيبي عملت ايه البروكوزل على
منظر الهروب سالبه هنا جنبي كده
[موسيقى]
تعجبني المراه القويه الطموحه الذكيه
المعتمده على نفسها
وساره فيها كل هذا الصفات بالاضافه لانها
اجمل بنت شفتها في حياتي
وهي بالنسبه لي حبيبتي صديقتي واهلي
ونحن حاليا مخطوبين
زواجنا في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
المثليه الجنسيه لدى النساء في الفلك
الممنوع والبدايه من هنا في استديو باريس
مع الناشطه الحقوقيه داليا شغال والمترجمه
صاحبه بوتكس المتعه الثالثه فالنتينا
تحسيناتو اهلا بكما انتما في علاقه حب منذ
ثلاث سنوات وتعيشان حاليا معا في احدى
الدول الاوروبيه
علاقتهما علانيه وانت بالتحديد داليا لديك
نضال طويل
الشجاعه بالخروج من الخزانه كما يقال
وبالاشهار ميولك الجندريه امام الجميع حتى
امام العائله ماذا يعني ان تحب امراه اخرى
وهل الكونك مثليه جنسيه من اصول عربيه
يجبرك على الخروج من بلدك مقابل الخروج من
الخزانه وانا بالنسبه لي مش السبب الرئيسي
ان انا ست مصر ما كانش بالتحديد ميولي فقط
همم اشترك طبعا همم مع همم
مش موده
في فكره انه
المراه في مصر مش بتقدر
تحقق نفسها بشكل يهز ما كانتش بتنتمي
لطبقه اقتصاديه اجتماعيه معينه وحتى في
ظروف زي دي بتبقى مضطره انها تقدم تنازلات
كثير انا كمان كنت عايشه لوحدي ست اهلي
وانا عندي 21 سنه كان موضوع مرعب جدا همم
تهديدات بالقتل حتى من اهلي يعني من عائله
الاكبر
فاكيد يعني ما حبتش اعيش عيشه بالشكل ده
يعني حاسه دائما بالتديد همم الاوبشنز
بتاعتي في الحياه مش كثير سكن مش عارفه
تكون شغل مش عارفه اشتغل باتعرض انتهاكات
بشكل او باخر عايشه حياه سرفايفل يعني همم
صراع بقاء
حتى لو في كومنتي كلنا في حاجه لدعم يعني
الموضوع كان صعب
فلما طلعت بره مصر ما كانشف بالي بالتحديد
ميولي همم ما كانش على اول القائمه لانه
انا كنت قادره في خطر كانت
اسباب اخرى غير ميول كمان همم هويتي ب
التقاطعاتها كانت ماثره على وضعي فقررت ان
انا امشي زي ناس كثير ما بتمشي من مصر
لاسباب اقتصاديه انا برده كان في جزء منها
سبب اقتصاديه
ولما طبعا انا ما كانش في بالي كان اكبر
توقعاتي ان انا مثلا ارتبط باحد بس ما
كانش على بالي ان انا اتكلم او اخرج من
الخزانه زي ما بيقولوا اا كان الفكره
الرئيسيه ان انا ابقى نفسي بعيدا بقى
هابقى ازاي هاعمل ايه هابقى مع مين ما
كانتش دي الفكره الرئيسيه طبعا ده كان
مستحيل حتى افكر فيه في مصر ان انا ما فيش
سيفتي نت لو وقعت انا غير موجوده اه حتى
الان انا لو رجعت مصر همم هاتحول لساحره
على همم خشبه بقى ويحرقه في الفكره انه
انا ما عنديش امكانيه ما كانش عندي
امكانيات ان انا اكون نفسي في مصر باي
صوره همم طبعا لكن وانا كمان لا يصدق لان
ممكن ان تحب امراه امراه ماذا يعني تحب
سيده سيده عادي بتحبها عادي يعني كله بيحب
كله كله كل واحد حر يحب اللي هو عاوزه
يعني ومش الحب بس يعني حتى الجنس نفسه
يعني كفكره يعني مش فاهمه احنا ليه بنقعد
نركز على الحب كمفهوم هو الليجيتامز او
بيبرر همم اي علاقه ما بين شخصين او اكثر
فالموضوع اكبر من كده يعني همم كلنا عندنا
حريه شخصيه ونعمل اللي احنا عاوزينه لا
ضرر ولا ضرار وكل واحد في حاله
كثير من المشاهدين والمشاهدات انه ربما
يعني من الصور النمطيه رائعه جدا انا من
التاك او من المؤكد ان داليا عاش التجربه
فاشله او صادمه مع رجل ما في حياتها
وبالتالي قررت ان تتجه انهما النساء الى
اي مدى هذا الامر صحيح يعني ده مش صحيح
يعني مش عارفه مش صحيح مش صحيح خالص يعني
اكيد همم
النرجسيه الديكوريه دائما بتتخيل من كل
حاجه بتتمحور حوالين القضيب وفكره الرجل
اللي هو مركزك بس ده مش حقيقي معلش سوري
ههه الموضوع مش كده خالص
اذا انت يعني تحبين تحبين المراه
وهذا امر يعني فعلا فطري هو طبيعي بالنسبه
يعني الموضوع برده ليه
متطلبات اخرى يعني
اه في ناس بتعجبني في ناس بتعجبنيش زي ما
برده في العلاقات الغيريه ما فيش حد يعجبك
وفي حد ما يعجبكيش طبعا يعني هو امر شخصي
جدا وذاتي وله علاقه في الذوق الانسان
يعني ومايل الانسان احساس الانسان طيب همم
ساذهب الى فالنتينا فالنتينا اليوم ربما
التحديات التي تواجه المراه الغربيه كما
يقال عندما تقرر ان تكون امراه مع علاقه
اخرى مختلفه هل هل تتشاركين نفس التحديات
مع داليا في مكان ما ام انك تشعرين ان
الامر اكثر سهوله او قبولا في المجتمعات
الغربيه في اوروبا في المجتمع الغربيه همم
ان هناك امور مشتركه بين النساء
في اوروبا
رغما
ودوت فامبير اذا لدينا العديد من الفضاءات
للقاء ويمكن ان نعيش مثل الجميع لدينا
لقاءات في الحالات مثلا او يمكن لنا اقامه
مواعيد غراميه وهذا الواقعي يتحسن مع
الوقت
ولكن الكثير من الهموم
ليس سهلا حتى هنا ان نبرر نفسنا بشكل دائم
كما ان العنف اذا انا لا يزال موجود في
اوروبا ايضا
على هذا السؤال فانا لا ابحث عن الحب في
كل امراه فقط
ليس فقط
انظر الى عنان جميلتين مثلا فاعجبوا
بالشخص
ساعود اليكم ما ساذهب الان الى بيروت مع
تجربه اخرى في الكثير من الشجاعه والجراه
هي قصه شابه لبنانيه مثليه الفنانه
الكوميديه شهد الفقيه اهلا بك شادا انت يا
شهد اعلنتي عن ميولكي الجندريه امام
العائله امام المجتمع امام العلن خلال
عروضك الكوميديه في بيروت وفي كل انحاء
العالم لديك جراه كبيره في هذا الايطار
وتتحدثين عن الموضوع بشكل بدون قيود
الملفت كان ان المحيط العائلي تقبل همم
هذا الامر هل تعتبرين في البدايه انك
محظوظه وهل ساعدتك الكوميديا في كسر هذا
التابوت مع المحيط العائلي ومع المجتمع
بشكل عام محظوظه اكيد محظوظه يعني همم
يعني انا كثير همم
كثير همم
لديك كميه كبيره نعم
نعم همم
وتقدير وتقدير انه شو طلع لي يعني خصيصا
من اهل ممتنا من اهل ومن محيطه لانه هي مش
بس عائله هي اولا امي وابي
عطوني سندي يعني ان السند الاقوى سند وهن
كمان حطوا مثل همم
[موسيقى]
ومن هون بتقلل يعني اذا انت اهلك بيعرفوا
هو نحن علاقتنا مع اهلنا كثير شفافه يعني
انا باعتقد
بالاجال في كل الاجيال القديمه كانت عم
توريط همم ممنوع نقول كلمه صح
عم بتوري تمشي كلها يعني
الحديد ما بيجي حدا وبيكسر هذا السيكل
عرفت كيف انا اهلي والناس اللي بلش يكسروا
هذا السيكل
بالضبط ومن هيك هذا سهل الموضوع الي لانه
هن بلشوا نضالن قبل مع انه اذا بتشوفي اهل
ثلاثه ارباع اصدقائنا ثلاثه ارباع الناس
الي بهالمجتمع اللي عايشين فيه ما مكسرين
هذه الدايره
السامه
الحريه الحريه الشخصيه الفكريه همم
هل تاتي من شبكه الامان في البلد يجرم في
مكان المثليه الجنسيه هل تشعرين انك
تعيشين كاي امراه اخرى في لبنان بدون خوف
ام انك بفضل هذه الشبكه شبكه الامان
العائليه تمكنت ربما متحدي هذا الخوف
مثليه بس كامراه اولا كمان يعني هذه
وكاميرا امثليه هذه حصانه يعني انا مثلا
سامعه قصص
بعض الاصدقاء او المقربين مثلا كانوا
بموقع خطر همم بس لانه هنا بموقع الخطوره
جاي منها هويتهم الجنسيه او الجندري ما
بيروحوا عند اهلهم ما عندهم المكان امن
يروحوا فبفضل يكون وبي خطر من انه يكونوا
مع اهله
فعرفتش قصدي انه اهلا وسهلا فهي دي حصانه
فاكيد هذه جيبتها انا من اهله ومن محيط
يعني انا كانت طبقه متوسطه يعني كمان نحكي
عن هذا الموضوع انه في موضوع طب همم
بالناس اللي حواليك بمفهومه بافكارهم
بكلها الموضوع له اجتماعي يعني
عن هذه الميول يتعلق ايضا بالطبقه هو
موضوع الطبقي للاسف وهو موضوع ايضا يختلف
بين الرجال والنساء ماذا تتحدث عن هذا
الامر ولكن اريد ان اسالك سؤال يعني همم
له علاقه بكيف تعارفين انت عن نفسك اليوم
ما الذي تحبينه في النساء ولا تجدينه في
الرجال اوكي بس بدي اوضح انه همم باعتقد
النساء كيف بيحسوا يعني انا اذا شفت هلا
امراه مزلطه همم
لانه
كبزاز عندي
بس انا اللي بيشدني بالمره وهو همم
المراه همم
بتاعه الرجل في حياتك يعني هل هو فقط يلعب
دور الاب دور الاخ دور الصديق لا يمكن ان
يكون حبيب اطلاقا مستحيل دوره هو اول عن
همم وتكون في صرصور هوت له همم هيدا اهمد
همم امل بصداقات وحب عذري بحث همم ومستحيل
يكون في همم انجذاب عرفت
كومبلكس المراه عند همم مليون طبقه فيها
في المره عشيره تمام سعودي اليك يبقى معنا
همم
ساعتها اذهب الى عكا مع الناشطه النسويه
الكوريه الفلسطينيه هذه الشافعي اهلا بك
غدير وشكرا لحضورك تشير اليوم العديد من
الشهادات للنساء مثليات عربيات
يعني تجربه شادن ربما تخرج عن اطار
التجارب التي همم
نستمع اليها او نقرا عنها في الدول
العربيه هناك صعوبه كبيره في الخروج الى
العلم في التعبير عن الميول الجندريه عن
الهويه الجندريه خاصه في المحيط العائلي
القريب وخلال الاعداد لهذه الحلقه واجهنا
صعوبه كبيره في اقناع شابات ونساء مثليات
عربيات بمشارتنا هذه القصص حتى ولو كانت
الهويه مخفيه يعني هناك خوف مضاعف لدى
النساء مجتمع علمي معين بالظهور علنا اكثر
من رجال هذا المجتمع كيف تفسرين هذا الامر
بفكر انه كثير مهم نحكي اول شيء كل القمع
والتمييز الجندري ضد المراه كل النساء
وهذا قمع عالم يعني كل نساء العالم تعاني
منه وليست النساء العربيه او الفلسطينيه
فاضافه الى هذا القمع
طويل همم معسكر والى اخره
باسم العادات والتقاليد فنحن نرى يعني
واحده المجتمعات اللي انا العربيه عن
المراه يعني تختزل المشاعرها وحرياتها
وتقلص حتى تتلاشى ليزدهر
اا الرجل العربي او تزدهر العادات
والتقاليد او طبعا الافكار او الحديث باسم
الدين اللي هو همم مش كثير شرعي فكثير مهم
نشوف هاي يعني نشوف همم التماجيه او حياه
النساء او تحديات حياه النساء المصريات
والكوريات ضمن هذا السياق
فعشان النساء ولا الرجال
والحاجه الى الحياه همم
الغرب او البحث عن الامان في مكان ثاني
بتاسيس اصوات المهم انه احنا نحكي عن كل
دوائر القناعه يعني سمعنا اصوات نساء
فلسطيني
القمع لا ياتي بمعذر فانه لما نحنا بنحكي
عن توني انا فلسطينيين عايش تحت الاحتلال
وممارسات العنف والاستعمار وسياسات
التمييز العنصري وايضا كان نساء في مجتمع
ابوي قام معسكر
في بعض الاحيان وايضا كان نساء مثليات
بيظل ايهاب المثليه لهم
في سلسله الغسيل الوردي اذا بنحكي كمان
على استيقاظ فلسطين مهم جدا احنا هنشوف
هذه التقاطع
لانه بكل مجتمعاتنا العربيه
لا يمكن الحديث عن حريات الجنسيه
والجندريه بمعزل عن همم الحريه
من الرباط المفكر والنشاط الحقوق العلماني
الاستاذ احمد عصيد استاذ احمد اول شيء
شكرا جزيلا على قبولك دعواتنا لهذه الحلقه
انت كالعاده يعني اضافه في برنامج الشفاء
لك الممنوع اريد ان اسال اليوم الى اي
درجه ممكن ان نقول ان تاريخ المسلمين
والعرب متصالح مع فكره المثليه متصالح
واكلها بين مزدوجين مع فكره المثليه لدى
النساء اكثر من تلك لدى الرجال وكيف
يفسروا هذا الامر تقسيم الادوار بين
الجنسين المذكر والمؤنث اقيم عليه نظام
اجتماعي وتمت المحافظه على هذا النظام
الاجتماعي
بقياده سياسي ايضا جامده وبفكر فقه جامد
قام بتجميد النصوص وتجميد المجتمع معها
وهكذا على مدى مئات السنين بقي مفهوم
الذكوره مفهوما مرتبطا بالسلطه وكل ما
يخالف مصلحته هذا المفهوم يعتبر اهانه
لكرامه الذكوره وهنا يدخل ما تتحدثون هو
اليوم وهو المثليه الجنسيه او ليزبيان في
اوساط النساء فالمثليه الجنسيه في اوساط
النساء كانت منتشره في الحضاره الاسلاميه
سواء في ما قبل الاسلام او في البدايه
الاسلام او في العهد الاموي والعباسي وكان
الترائجا في الاوساط الاعيان خاصه
والخلفاء وفي القصور والبلاطات بسبب ما
سمي بالحريم الحريم كان يجعل ان نساء
كثيرات
تعتبرنا لرجل واحد ليس له امكانيه ان
يلتقي بهن كلهم فيبقين في العزله لمده
طويله وتنشا عن ذلك على علاقات مثليه هذا
بالاضافه الى وجود مثليه طبيعي عند كثير
من النساء كما تتحدث الاخوات اليوم فاذا
هناك اهانه مزدوجه للذكوره عندما تكون
هناك علاقه امراه اه وهذه الاهانه
المزدوجه تتمثل اولا في ان المذكر او
الذكر لا يقبل
شخصيه امراه قويه وتقوم بدور الرجل في
المضاجعه والوجه الثاني من الاهانه هو ان
هناك امراه اخرى
يمارس عليها الجنس وتتمتع في غياب الرجل
وهذا الشيء لا تقبله العقليه الذكوريه لان
الذكر يعتقد انه وحده الذي له العضو
الذكري الذي يمكن ان يمتع المراه هذا من
جهه من جهه اخرى النظام الاباوي الفطري
اركان كله الذي تعيش به دول شمال افريقيا
والشرق الاوسط منذ قرون قام على اساس ان
المراه المركز ان الرجل يوجد في المركز
وان المراه ملحق به لانتاجه وارضائه ونيل
رضاه وانها تخدمه وتطيعه وانه هو الذي
يتمتع وهي بالطبع تخدم هذه المتعه وحتى في
الطلاق قال الفقهاء المتعه سموا المال
الذي يقدمه الرجل للمراه عند الطلاق متعه
اي انه تمتع بها كما لو انها هي لا تتمتع
اذا المنظومه العلاقات الصوص يتقافيه ترفض
وجود المراه في المركز ترفض وجود المراه
في دور الرجل ترفض وجود المراه القويه
الشخصيه والتي لها جاذبيه وتجذب المراه
الرجل وحده ومن ينبغي ان يكون له جاذبيه
امام النساء وترفض كذلك ان تكون هناك متعه
في غياب المذكر تتحدث عن الموت
داليا طبعا يمكنك ان تعلق لو اردتي على ما
تفضل به السيد احمد واريد ان اسالك اليوم
كتب التراث العربي تسخر والاسلامي تسخر
بشخصيات تاريخيه منها مكان مقدس او يعني
مرتبط بالمقدس همم ويعني هناك نصوص كثيره
عن ما يسمى ما هو رائج يسمى بالسحاق اي
بالعلاقات المثليه بين النساء وسحاق لغويا
يجب ان يشرح فقط يعني اليوم لديه همم معنى
سلبي ولا يستخدم ولكن اسحق هو فعل الحفاف
باللغه العربيه وبالتالي هكذا كان يسمى
هناك نصوص ساخنه في هذا التراث اليوم يقول
السيد احمد المتعه الرجل يرفض او الرجل لن
يتحدث عن رجل اي رجل يتحدث عن المجتمع
ذكوري يرفض ان يخرج يرفض ان يخرج مفهوم
المتعه من من اطاره او من وجوده او من
اعضاءه التناسليه الى اي مدى هذا صحيح وهل
يمكن اليوم هناك هذه الصوره نمطيه هل يمكن
ان تصل المراه الى متعه بدون ايلاج بدون
عضو ذكريها هل هذا ممكن هو اكيد ممكن لانه
همم كل امراه عندها طرق مختلفه للوصول
للنشوه ده حتى مره عن مره ممكن تختلف يعني
متعه المراه فرنسيه عمرها ما كانت موضوع
او محور نقاش اصلا فكويس ان احنا في في
العصور دي او في العصر ده بنقدر نتكلم عن
حاجه زي كده لانه ما قبل ذلك حتى العضو
التناسلي او العضو الجنسي الانثوي لفظا
اللي هو له مرجعيه تركيه او فارسيه
يعني جاي من وظيفته بالنسبه للذكر انه هو
الفرش يعني لا ما همم يعني ده برده احد بس
كذا لفظ الاساس اللي هو اليوم شتيمه يعني
هو لغويا بالضبط
مش معناه همم معناه مرتبط بوظيفته نعم همم
حاجه ثانيه لها علاقه بالتاريخ همم هو
الطريق بتاع المراه عامه كان مطموس وما
زال بيتم طمسه بشكل قديم انا مش عاوزه
اقول ان الاسلام كان فصالح مع المثليه
الجنسيه ابدا ان هو زي اي دين ابراهيم زي
معتقدات كثير تاريخيه عندها مشكله مع همم
المراه ذكوريه تاريخها طويل طويل جدا
وقديم همم ويكون ان في بعض الظواهر او تم
تدوينها برده من منطلق ذكوري مش معناه ان
هو دي صوره الوحيد اللي كانت موجوده لها
مش معناها ان الاسلام كان متسامح وفي
طبقات ثانيه زي ما احنا بنتكلم عن الملوك
ولا الامراء
المتسامح ولكن هناك ربما كان قبول لهذه
العلاقات احنا ما نعرفش حاجه احنا بنتكلم
عن طبقه همم السقراطيه
مفاهيم عصرنا الحالي كان فيها اشياء احنا
يعني يعني لدينا اليوم بالنسبه اليك لا
يكفي لان استنتج مستحيل نستنتج حاجه زي
كده احنا بنبص على همم عالم مختلف تماما
كان في همم
طبقيه واضحه وصريحه يعني الملك السلطان
وفيما واللي تحته من الخليفه او الخليفه
طيب تمام فالنتينا اريد ان اسال سؤال ولا
تحدثت عن اديان ابراهيميه همم ايضا هذا
الموضوع يطرح فيما يتعلق بالهم وفوبيا
بملف الهموف فوبيا في الدول الاوروبيه
وعندما نتحدث عن بالتحديد عن النساء
المثليات دور الدين هنا برايك الى المدرسه
الى هذه العلاقات همم
في اوروبا ايضا اخذت بثقلها على العلاقات
المثليه
همم
فوق تمام
[موسيقى]
بالرجل بسبب هذه المعايير التي يفرض
المجتمع الذكوري شادا اريد ان اسالك سؤال
ربما اليوم هناك صور نمطيه كثيره خاصه عن
مثليات جنسيا منها ما هو همم اليوم ربما
ان المثليه جنسيه غالبا هي مسترجله هي
سيده غير جميله هي سيده تسعى لان تكون او
تلعب دور الرجل في العلاقه مع السيده
الاخرى ما رايك انت همم بشكل عام من اين
تاتي هذه النظاره بالنسبه اليك وكيف
تردينا على هذه النظره لانه ربما قد ينظر
الكثيرون اليوم الى سيدات مثليات ويقولون
هذا ما نقصده عندما نقول انها مسترجله
اسمعوا صوتها انظروا كيف تتكلم كيف تردين
على هذا النوع من الحجج وهذه الصور
النمطيه الرائجه اليوم اولا على الجميلات
عفوا عليه همم
سحاقيه وجميله شكرا
موضوع الجندل يعني انه عم نحكي عن
الازدواجيه يعني انه انا بشوف انه ال ال
الجندر هو مثل سبكترم حتى ما نسبه اكثر ما
هو شو مختلط بينه وبين الجنس
ولا حتى انه اشتريت او جاي هو شيء مخلوط
كله وفي وكل ما بتكوني حره بتعيش اكثر
طبعا همم اموره بتجنبها
المراه
المستلج همم والله كل صاحباته يعني همم
حاجات ما انت يعني بومبا
ومره مره وشو ما كان يعني مسترجله او لا
يعني شو يعني امراه
مسترده شو يعني
الرجل
لا نقول نحن يعني يقال انها معقده ويقال
انه يعني لديها مشاكل مع صوره الرجل
وبالتالي تسعى لان تكون رجلا
اوكي هلا هنا بيقولوا انه نحن بنكره
الرسائل
نحن بنكره الفكره الاجتماعيه الي بنحطت
لدور المراه ودور الرجال بهذا الموضوع
من وراءها المستوى الثالث
هذا
هو بكل بساطه هو
يعني كل شيء مستقل عنه للرجال هو سيء كل
شيء ما فيه سلطه وهو سيء شو ما كان شكله
يعني بدك تسميه سحاق بدك تسميه شو ما كان
يعني سلطه ماليه كلها لكل هو اللي من وراء
السلطه كلمه تروح السلطه كلمه اسوا لما
المراه
بالعصور الوسطى بلاشت هي ما تتكل على
الرجال الذين يجوا يصلوا يعملوا للمرضى
وتروح تقطف وتعمل اعشاب وعلاش بالاعشاب
كانت عم توقف بالسلطه بوش السلطه الدينيه
ههه
كل شيء ما بيفوت دون نهايه السلطه
وبيخسرهم سلطه هي شيء مختلف شيء شيء شيء
اسمه وفي كمان حتى بيقول لك انه بيكره هو
ال- ال- الاير بس هو لا انه يعني هو احنا
مملكه الايه
كعدوشي لذيذ معلق واللي معلق في شيء
اجتماعي هو لو معلق فيه مشغوله عليه يا
اما اتعوبه ليه بينحكى بس متعوبه عليه قد
ايه في نسبه الرجال عم تشتغل القمامهم قال
لك انه النساء كلها بتشتغل على حاله نساء
ذكريات موجودين وكلها لي هاشتاج نت
اولمنان هاشتاج ناتول ومانيا بس همم قد
ايه في نسبه اليوم الجايه اللي بتوقف
وبتشتغل على حاله وبتفك دي وقير انا اللي
قلته هلا انه مش مش اللي قلته هلا شيزو
كوري انا ليش عم بقول هذا الشيء انا ليش
بدي اقعد اعمل هذول قصص ما فيها
الانترسكشن يعني طيب
وبس على قصه الولوجيا
الرغم الجنسيه
مركز على لسه الرجال والمراه
اما هو المتعه
توشيبا حد ذاته بعد لا هلا يعني قد ايه في
همم دراسات عن تنعمل لازالت هلا عم تنعمل
يعني
غالبا دراسات التي الحياه الجنسيه تفضل
وما بيقدروا يستوعب انه اليوم التكيه ههه
عرفت انه في قطعت متعه لا انا ما بيعرف
على الجنسيه لا قالوا ان هي المتعه
بالقضيب هذا القضيب كثير
انه هذا الشيء منه
لانهلوج عرفت كيف على البنات
بس ما في مفهوم همم النساء
يعني هل يعني جدا جدا
يعني اليوم همم لماذا يقبل الكثير من
الرجال في المجتمعات العالميه وليس فقط في
العالم العربي عندما ندخل على الانترنت
على محرك البحث جوجل نضع النساء مثليات
اول ما يخرج هو افلام البورنو لماذا الرجل
يقبل ان يرى السيد المثليه او سيدتان
مثليتان في فيلم اباحي ويعني هو طبعا ربما
ده غالبيه الرجال هناك هذا الفانتازم ايضا
في في خيالي من الجنسي ولا يقبل بهن
كشركات في المجتمع موجودات
كل موضوع الجنس
النساء المثليه
همم جزء من العلاقه من الحب والمحبه
واسلوب حياه هو اسلوب حياه مختلف اكيد هو
اسلوب حياه يتطلع الى تعدديه يعني
هيك ناس عم تخلق ممكن ناس تخلق مثليه
مزدوجه
طبيعيه هي مش مرض هو مش شيء خارج عن
الطبيعه اه كان موجود بكل الحضارات وكل
الديانات ومن ضمن
تعال نفكر كمان انه احنا النساء نشارك
التجارب ثاني اللي هي
تتخطى يعني انه تجربنا لما احنا بنحكي عن
تجاربنا كان نساء مثليات او كبيريات او
عاهرات يعني همم شريحه كبيره من المجتمعنا
اللي بتسمعنا لاول مره لاني فتيات وكمان
فتيات ممكن نساء فتيات ورجال وشباب
وامهات وعمات وخالاتهم اول مره بيسمعوا
هذه القصه المهم
طبيعي
اذا فيه شخص مثل او مثلي المهم انه احنا
نكون حاضر
ان نتحدث اكثر في هذه الملفات وهي
ملفاتنا لانه بعض الناس يقولون انها ملفات
يعني تتحدثون عن ترهات الناس تموت من
الجوع وانتم تتحدثون عن المثليه الجنسيه
نعم تفضل لداليا بس بدي تعقب بس على فكره
يعني هو لان انا تجربتي الشخصيه لما تكلمت
لما خرجت من الخزانه ان فكره المواجهه
بالنسبه
للذكور صادمه همم النساء اللي بيمارسوا
الجنس مثلي خلف الشاشه دول واحد همم يعني
الجنس المثلي ده اللي احنا بنشوفه بشكل
مين ستريم او بشكل رائع هو مصنوع للرجال
فقط لا اثارتهم ده واحد رقم اثنين همم ما
فيش مواجهه اكيد مش هتطلع من الشاشه وتقول
له وايه اللي انت بتعمله ده يعني اكيد لا
مش هتقول انا اسمي كذا ولا هيكون مهتم
اصلا يعني ههه
انا ليه الناس بعثت لي رسائل ذبح قتل همم
عارفين عنوان بيتك في مصر اهلك مين
هنكلمهم هتدخلي السجن ابوك هيدخل السجن كل
الكلام ده ليه لان في مواجهه انا شخص له
اسم لشخصيه لصوت فيها اه مش عاوزين يسمعوا
ده
طيب استاذ احمد قبل هيك ان تنتهي الحلقه
اريد ان اسمع رايك في مساله هذه يعني
داليا قالت انه ايضا الممثلات في عالم
الافلام الاباحيه وافلام البورنو هن ادوات
اليوم الرجل الذي يعتبر نفسه مؤمنا ويحرم
هذه الممارسات لكنه يعني
يستعمله هذه الافلام كم منشطات جنسيه له
في حياته اليوميه كيف يمكن ان نقرا هذا
التناقض الفظيع في القيام في همم في النظر
الى الامور طبعا هذا نتاج التربيه
المنحرفه التي تسود في بلدان شمال افريقيا
والشرق الاوسط وهي تربيه تركز على المثال
الديني وتغض الطرف عن حقائق الواقع
ومفارقاته ولهذا نربي الناس على ان يقولوا
ما يريده المجتمع وما يريده النظام
الاباوي وليس ما يريدنه هم ولهذا يقمع الم
لانه لا تعطاه الكلمه لكي لا يعبر عن شيء
مخالف للنظام الاجتماعي
فالمثليه بين النساء تخلخل هذا النظام
الاجتماعي الابوي وتضر بمصالح الذكور وهذا
ما يجيب على سؤال الاخت التي طرحت قبل
قليل لماذا الرجل يعني يرفض يرفض لانه ما
يتعلق بالمثل بين النساء شيء يهينه ذكورته
ويخلخل كل النظام الذي يشتغل لمصلحته
وطبعا اليوم لا احد يتحدث عن موقف الشريعه
في الفقهاء يخفونه لان فيه عقوبات قاسيه
فيه القتل وفيه الجلد وهم لم يعودوا يزرون
اليوم عن الحديث
المجتمع يتجاوزهم لكن اعتقد اننا نحن
المؤمنون بالحريه والمؤمنون بالانسان
وبالكرامه الانسانيه علينا ان ندافع عن
امرين اثنين الاول
ضروره
المعرفه العلميه بمعنى المثلي لان في كل
هذه المجتمعات هناك جهل كبير وامنيه لا
يعرف الناس ما معنى المثل من الناحيه
العلميه يعتقدون انه مجرم وانه منحرف وهم
لا يعرفون بان حتى المنطق الديني الذي
يستعملونه هو ضدهم لان المنطق الدين يقول
ان الله يخلق البشر على على صورته وهل
معنى هذا انه لم يخلق المثليين فاذا حتى
في المنطق الديني نفسه همم يعني هذا
الخطاب لا يمكن ان يصمد من المساله
الثانيه هو التربيه على الحق في الاختلاف
وعلى العيش المشترك هدني المفهومان
المهمان جدا وهما مطرودان من المدرسه في
هذه الرقعه الجغرافيه التعيسه لابد من
تربيه اطفالنا على ان سلموا المختلف في
اللون وفي اللسان وفي العقيده وفي الميول
الجنسيه واعتبار ان اختلاف الميولوجيا
تغيير ليس جريمه بل هو شيء
لا تغير القوانين هذا الشيء الجوهري ونحن
الان في هذه الايام في المغرب في خضم
النقاش حول القانون الجنائي ومدونه الاسره
وتطرح كل هذه الاشياء بحده الان واعتقد
انه من اجل مواطن متوازن رجلا كان ام
امراه ومن اجل حياه كريمه لابد من احترام
الحق اختيار نمط الحياه الدوله ليس من
حقها التدخل بين الشخص ونفسه في حياته
الخاصه وليس من حقها التدخل في اختيارات
في اللباس والاكل والشرب
والجنس والفن والابداع الجمال هذه اشياء
للانسان ان يقرر فيها بنفسه ما السعاده
في هذه البلدان لان السعاده مرتبطه اساسا
بالحريه شكرا لك يا استاذ احمد كلمه اخيره
همم داليا فيما يتعلق اريدها خاصه قليلا
انت ما الذي تقولينه اليوم لكل فتاه ربما
عربيه همم
مثليه ولكنها تخاف من المواجهه تخاف من ان
تقول عن همم ما تشعر او ان تعبر عن هويتها
همم انا انا بصراحه ما اقدرش اقدم نصيحه
كامله للجميع همم هي اول شيء اهم شيء
الامان الواحد يكون في امان ولو همم قدري
يلاقي احد يفصح ليه عن ميوله يكون شخص امن
واكيد في ناس هتكون امنه في البدايه بعد
كده ما تكونش امنه امم التكيف في القدره
على التكيف دي برده مهاره ومش كل قادر
عليها ف- ما عنديش نصيحه عشان كامله همم
لان ظروفنا مختلفه
يعني احد فقاريه مثلا حياته اكيد هتكون
مختلفه
يعني ففي سياقات كثيره في ناس اعرفهم في
دول اوروبيه مش قادرين يقولوا لاهلهم ولا
يقولوا لحد بالرغم ان القوانين بتخدمهم
ههه احنا بنتكلم عن تعقيدات
شخصيه جدا يعني كل شخص له طريقته في
التغلب على ال- همم
الاطار يعني علاقات المثليه بين النساء
سيكون جميلا لو في كل العالم وليس فقط في
العالم العربي او اوروبا ان يفهم الناس
انهم يتعاملون مع بشر مثلهم وان الحب
المثليين هو حب وانا العلاقات الجنسيه
المثليه اياك غيرها من العلاقات الجنسيه
[موسيقى]
ما بيتقبل همم انه في مثليين وهو بيعتقد
انه في ترويج للمثليين وهو للناس انتم مش
عم بتخلوا الناس ما تكون مثلي الناس حد
الله مثليين او حد الله شو ما كانت هي
خلقه شو ما كانت هي حد الله الفرق بس انه
حتى
تكرهها الناس اكثر وحتكون حقيقتها بخطر
اكتر ما يعني ان هي هتغير اذا اليوم انا
جيت قلت لابني انه ممنوع تكون لوطي انه
ايه مش انه حيوقف اذا الله انه اذا عرفت
اذا مين ما كان اذا قال انه انا ممنوع
اكون هيك بالاخير اللي عم بتحسي هو الفرق
الوحيد هو احساسه للشخص مع نفسه واحساس
المجتمع تجاهه اليوم طالما انتم عم تخلو
شخص كان نفسه
يؤذون الناس همم نسبه الانتحار عند لحظه
بس كمان في نسبه انسحار سوري همم
بس هي حلوا عني انا كل واحد يعيش مثل ما
بدو يا الله شو بيتكم فينا ههه شكرا همم
لكن همم شكرا للجميع الضيوف والضعيفات في
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ممنوعه النقاش لا
نهايه
التفكير وحوريه الاختيار دائما على
انفلونزا تحياتي
[موسيقى]